so I hate to be the one to bring this to
your attention but I fear that you are
unhappy and I think that most of your
unhappiness is an outgrowth of dealing
with other people and I have two reasons
for thinking this one is that you know I
wrote I wrote code from probably a
longer period of time than most of your
lives and now I travel and I teach so I
dip in and out of shops like programming
shops ten or twelve times a year and so
I see unhappiness on the ground all
kinds of unhappiness in different places
so I see it that's one reason I believe
that you're unhappy but it's but I also
believe that you're unhappy because
there's a study about it came out this
summer for people some of whose names I
cannot pronounce so I won't even try
this is a they describe it as being on
the distribution and causes a programmer
unhappiness and so here's what they did
they harvested half a million email
addresses from github and then they
randomly selected 33,000 people and of
those they sent out surveys and they
ended up getting 1,300 and some
responses they correspond it back and
forth with those people and they ended
up identifying 219 specific kinds of
ways to be unhappy all right and so they
took those 219 unhappiness codes and
they send them back to this group of
people and had them rank which ones
causes them unhappiness and they got
back a total of 2,200 some references to
codes now of course and that's like 10
10 average all right 10 votes per
average for some kind of unhappiness but
of course it turns out the distribution
is not that even here are the top 10
causes a programmer unhappiness being
stuck I don't know that I find that kind
of weird because I sort of think that's
fun but what do I know
all right time bad code underperforming
colleagues I thought that was super
interesting I wondered if they're called
they're underperforming colleague got
the survey if they would say this like
is it a circular firing squad kind of
thing
feelings of inadequacy boring things
unexplained so goes on and on so I found
this list super interesting and you
notice they categorize some things as
internal in some is external
I am not all that interested in the
internal things I'm gonna agree that
they're important but they're not about
this talk alright so I'm gonna get rid
of them and this I I just don't buy that
feeling board is external so I'm because
I'm up here and I have this in my hand
I'm just gonna get rid of that too and
[Applause]
so now we're left with these six right
this accounts for 500 like this is a
large proportion of the reason that we
report for being unhappy and if you look
at these six things you can really
decide I believe that the root cause of
all these things is other people that's
what we're saying other people can be so
annoying like you probably know how to
fix all those things right you have an
idea but it's other people that keep
making mistakes it causing pain that
causes pain to roll downhill to you if
only they would behave the way you want
them to behave everything would be
better and so if despite your best
efforts you've been unable to get people
to behave the way you want them to
behave this is obviously a problem of
persuasion and now it's the time for me
to confess that I have degree in
psychology and this is something from
which one never recovers it is really
shaped how I think about the world and
so when I see groups of humans who are
unhappy because they can't come to
agreement I see it as a problem of
persuasion and this makes me sad this
shouldn't happen because it turns out
that humans are absolutely hardwired to
be persuadable like in the early days of
human evolution the world is scary and
dark and when groups of humans that
could bind together in collaborate live
to reproduce this is how evolution works
right we are products of the process
that selected us for cooperation and
when people can't get along
some there's a fundamental systemic
failure in our interactions there's lots
and lots of research about this there's
lots of data about the ways in which we
were persuadable and I'm gonna take you
through a couple of different points of
view about how persuasion works here's
one perspective this guy's named CEO
Dini I think I'm not Italian Robert
Steele Dini he wrote this book the
psychology of suasion persuasion it has
sold three million copies I have a book
and it will never sell three million
copies this is all this is a lot of
books right so he goes through in this
book he goes through a bunch of research
about persuasion in the end subgrouping
kinds of persuasion into six categories
and so he has a he develops a framework
to talk about persuasion and I'm gonna
go through those categories tell you
what they are the first one the first
one about persuasion is the rule of
reciprocity and here's what the rule
says it says that if I give you
something or help you in a way then you
are if I attempt to help you if I
attempt to do you a favor you are
obligated to take it and you are
obligated to reciprocate and you are
obligated to reciprocate I can ask you
for something back even before you
volunteer it and I can ask you for
something back that is bigger than what
I gave you that's what the rule says
it's it's interesting this is a rule
that saddles humans with a future
obligation and the evolutionary basis of
this is I can give something away
without losing it I can give you food or
shelter or space at my fire knowing that
it doesn't really actually go away for
me and so you can you can really see how
the rest of POC the reciprocity rule
would make it so that we groups of
humans could survive because it's so
hardwired into us it's extremely easy to
exploit see me know who these guys are
yeah you're too young it's really scary
there Hari Krishna's yeah and so back in
the 80s notice what they have in those
baskets they're giving away flowers and
here's how they have a hesitation
hesitate to use the word scam they have
a thing they have a fundraising
opportunity and this is how it works
they gave you a flower and then they
asked you for donation and it really
exploits the reciprocity rule right
nobody wants the flower like you know
like in the 80s all the airports in
America were full of these people and
they would you would like sneak around
through the main like lobby trying to
avoid making eye contact with a Hare
Krishna because they would give me that
flower it was really hard to turn it
down and when she took it it was really
hard to refuse to give them a donation
that it's it's an illustration of how
powerful this rules people so if you
could not avoid being having a flower
forced on you people just throw them
away around the next corner and it turns
out they actually there would be someone
on the Krishna team whose job was to go
take the discarded flowers out of trash
cans and bring him back for recycling
like they totally understood that they
were abusing this role and it really
offended people so much so that the
reason you don't see this anymore is in
1992 the Port Authority of New York City
brought a case that went all the way to
Supreme Court that banned soliciting
like this in public spaces in America we
hated that we don't want to be used in
this way because this rule is important
to us and we don't want to see it
violated ok that's rule number one rule
number two is consistency it turns out
we have a strong built-in desire to
continue to appear consistence of things
statements we've made earlier one way
you see this exploited is that you know
that thing parents should know it yeah
thing we're in november/december on
Saturday mornings this time of year
their ads on the Saturday morning
cartoons for the new toy and your child
begs you for that toy you promise that
you will bring it to them for Christmas
and then you find that it is unavailable
in any store right and so you eventually
break down and you buy them something
else and then mysteriously after the
holidays the ads reappear and now and
now the toys are in the stores and your
child says your child sees the ads and
they say can you get me the whatever it
is and you say well I got you Christmas
and they say but you promised
i time occurs do this on purpose because
they're trying to spread their sales
cycle out for the whole year and this is
a way they can make you buy in December
and then they can make you buy again in
January it's deliberate the fact that
those toys are unavailable in December I
know it's kind of just kind of makes me
grumpy sir I should switch slides all
right so the third rule is about social
proof we had a social proof example the
other day when the fire alarm went off
right social proof says if I don't know
what to do in time especially in times
of uncertainty I will do what others do
like I know the social proof rule I was
standing with a group of people in the
hallway and I'm like let's go all right
it's hard to make that action is rule
all the time I'm a I'm a cyclist and it
is common to be on a long ride and that
is absent of facilities shall we say and
then you're in the woods that's what's
happening right and it doesn't matter
how rule the road is as soon as you get
off your bike and go off in the woods
cars start going by and and if you have
a your friend your set of colorfully
dressed cyclists they're standing by the
road like all the cars go by and they
look at those cyclists and then we
there's a possibility that you offend
the sensibilities at this point right
and so we've developed a street a scheme
a strategy like I can absolutely control
the gaze of passers-by and here's what
you do you sell your friends when car
when a car comes to fixedly stare in the
opposite direction and you can watch it
cars come up all the heads in the car
turn to the cyclist and then they all
turn and look in the direction of their
gaze
totally works right social proof so rule
number four is about Authority there's
two kinds of Authority really there's
this there's a the kind of authority
that's exhibited by people in uniforms
right this is the obey me kind of
Authority judges cops teachers we they
have a role in society and we agree that
we will be persuaded by the things they
say because of their role there's also
another kind of authority which is
called expert authority we use it that a
lot here right like I learned TDD
because some expert told me I ought to
and believe me my initial experience was
not good I went from being a super well
feeling as if I was a super competent
program into being absolutely
accomplishing zero from one day to the
next because of my attempts to do TDD
but I persevered because I thought that
the expert was right right it's it's a
way to shortcut decision-making about
things that we don't know enough about
and that can be super handy but it can
also go badly wrong you can imagine the
second-to-the-last rule is about liking
we if if people like you they're more
likely to do what you want now I know
that you're probably having a big duh
right now but but think about that like
liking is so biologically hardwired into
us that we never really examine what
it's about it's amazingly powerful right
why do we like people what purpose does
liking serve we tend to like people who
are similar to us and we tend to like
people who have we've had positive
interactions with in the past um you
know that feeling so liking is linked
okay so liking is linked to trust and
it's about trusting that they'll
reciprocate so there's this binding of
community that goes with liking you know
that this explains why it feels so
creepy if someone is over friendly right
have you ever had that feeling it's like
I didn't know we were this good of
friends there's a there's a feeling
you're suspicious of people who are
overly friendly for no reason because
you you
and implicitly that you're being bound
in an obligation that you might not want
to fulfill and so waiking is so
hardwired into us that we rarely examine
it but it's an it's interesting to ask
right as liking exists like what is the
origin of this phenomena and finally the
last general category for academia is
something called scarcity we tend to
value things more if we feel like
there's few of them right this is why
Amazon taser tells you there's only
seven left right the value of things go
up when there are fewer of them and this
this explains some really curious
phenomena you know it is not your
imagination that they go more slowly
when you were waiting on that perfect
place you're right and the people who
are leaving like if you're waiting if
someone's backing out of a place and you
park your car and wait what happens is
the the space becomes more valuable
because you also want it and the drivers
who are leaving that space report that
they are hustling that they are moving
more quickly because you're waiting but
if you measure it they're actually going
more slowly the only way you can make
them go even slower still is to blow
your horn okay that because what it does
is it signifies how valuable you find
that space the more value you place on
it and if they can see it the more
reluctant they are to let it go that's
the principle scarcity and so there you
go that's all of salvini these six
properties I they feel in many ways they
feel like triumphs of human nature to me
like they feel like very positive things
and yet see Leaney describes them in
this book just weapons of influence now
I'm gonna brief digression I am really
careful about how many key no effects I
use because it feels like you could get
bored with it but did you notice how
well Andy did yesterday morning here's
everything use that wall falling over
thing a million times and I never hated
him for it so I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna play that again
so I got so this book truly is about
weaponizing these things and I have to
tell you I hated it
it really offended me I'm gonna read you
two quotes from the first chapter he's
talking about these things as weapons of
influence their strength is in the
nearly mechanical process by which the
power within these weapons can be
activated and the consequent
exploitability of this power by anyone
who knows how to trigger them that's
great
here's another quote the great their
great advantage is not only that they
work but also that they are virtually
undetectable all right yeah okay we
don't you don't you love that so these
things are hardwired right stimulus lead
response if you know if you're aware of
these rules you can absolutely use them
to your advantage this book is about
selling people things and it's also
doing that if you don't understand these
rules you should you should probably not
be allowed to go buy a car by yourself
but don't go in the car lot all right
cuz they all know and so I really
appreciate these qualities of humans and
I hate the idea that we're gonna
surreptitiously in a non-transparent way
try to exploit them to manipulate other
people and so despite the fact that the
research is completely valid I hate this
point of view so I'm looking for another
one and I found this from the days of
black and white this is it's Dale
Carnegie you bet he wrote this book how
to win friends and influence people and
I'm just gonna run you hid the book is
in four sections I had never read it
like we're all aware of it right
probably everybody in here has heard of
it I'd never read it it comes in four
sections each section is ends with a
list of the principles covered in that
section so I'm just going to show you
the sections and let the principles run
and chat underneath it all right so the
first section is how to make people like
you notice it liking like this his book
is opinion right it's personal
experience but notice how closely these
map into the things that we just talked
about with seal doing this the first one
is about liking there are six things in
this category this is what you have to
do
I can promise you if he did those things
to me I would like you that would
totally work right all right here's the
next category's about handling people
it's got three things in it okay all
right and then now this is the longest
one there's 12 things in this category
this is how to win people over so this
goes more directly to pursuade ability
at some point about here I started
feeling inadequate I mean it's like oh
no imagine the world if we all behaved
like that
throw down a challenge is it's about
that consistency like it turns out if
you describe people if you say your
civic minded kind of person perhaps
you'll help me get out the vote people
you hang that labeling people they'll
live up to it that's what that's about
so one last one be leader there's nine
things in this category why you read
these I want you to think about what
would work be like if your bosses did
this
you have clearly seen this face
new haircut at all and when I talked to
Sara about this talk I told her I was
reading a karna game that I'd never read
it and she offered me a one-line
synopsis a plot synopsis by cliff notes
of Carnegie and this is what she said I
think there's a lot of truth in that
there's a lot of truth in that
there's there's actually the Carnegie
people would say one more thing about
the point of view of all the things in
this book think about every one of those
things was not about the other person
it's about you like Carnegie's about
changing the way you behave his theory
is that if you change your behavior you
can change the behavior of others it's
very definitely about you and so this
make people like you handle them
respectively win them over and be a
leader so if you want and if you want
people to be persuaded to your point of
view you can do that by changing your
own behavior and and I have to say that
I like that a lot better than the other
point of view right and so here we are
we have these things who are unhappy I'm
sure you forgot that but we are and it's
because of other people we hate that and
then we have these two sort of broad
sort of frameworks that we can use to
persuade people you can use the again
weaponize you can weaponize influence
like sealed sealed Eenie tells you and
it would probably work or you can use
the internally focused things of
Carnegie and that would probably work
too but at this point there's a question
we haven't asked yet and it's now time
to break it up to bring it up what if it
is possible everything that we've talked
about so far is assuming that you're
right
that the best thing to do would be if
they behave the way you want them to
behave alright and now I think we have
to look really hard at that assumption
right how do you know that you're right
how do I know that you should be doing
TDD how can I prove it is better if you
make small objects how can I say that my
style got just better than yours like we
don't have any facts and I like to think
that facts are facts still even in the
modern world and that we are persuadable
by facts but we don't have them very
much of what we do what we think about
writing software boils down to opinion
and so and the arguments I see when I go
out in the world the arguments are about
not ends they're not about what we
should try to achieve they're about how
to achieve it alright and so we're
having these big fights like either one
of two things is true the people that
you disagree with are evil and their
intent is to destroy your application
that's one thing right or they have the
same lofty goals as you and they've
chosen different means and so it's
possible that we are more alike than we
are different but you would never know
it from my point of view when I got on
the road you would never know it based
on the viciousness of the disagreements
now I think that we do share common
goals I do not think the people that
disagree with us are evil and I'm I
think that not only because I believe in
your good intentions I do but I also
know what motivates you and if you
understood their motivations you would
be better equipped to forge agreements
so why is it that we do the things we do
and how can we motivate people to do
work and it turns out this is a problem
that's tractable to research - in 2010 a
guy named Daniel pink published this
book he did a bunch of research at MIT
what do you what he did was he had
people play puzzles and memorize word
lists and shoot ball sir hoops all kinds
of tasks and he was any incentivized
performance with the money right so if
you did it if you did a little bit of
good you get a little bit of money if
you get kind of a medium kind of good
you get him even money if you did really
good you'd get a lot of money kind of
like work is supposed to work
right it was that thing and he and
here's what he found as long as the task
was purely mechanical if you do this
then that happens stuff the money
actually did work higher amounts of
money created higher incentives which
gave led to better performance but as
soon as the task became at all creative
whenever there's any kind of cognitive
component to the task higher rewards led
to worse performance and this is not one
of this you know modern sociological
studies it has not been replicated this
has been replicated all over all kinds
of different people like this is a fact
in terms of for simple straightforward
if you know if you do this is that
happens task money and centers work
great but if you need conceptual
creative thinking that those kind of
motivations don't work it's it's not
that money isn't a motivator money is
but you just have to pay people enough
to get money off the table like as soon
as you pay him enough so that money is
not an issue other things are more far
more important about motivation so pink
found three things there are three
things that operate to motivate is the
first one is a desire for autonomy we
want to control our own lives the second
one is a drive to mastery we want to get
better at things and the third one is a
desire for purpose we want our lives to
have meaning for those of you aren't who
have never done this you may not
recognize that that young man is out on
a very early on a cold morning on the
roof of a house that's being built by
Habitat for Humanity in Dallas he's
building someone a house purpose we want
to do something we want to work for
something bigger than ourselves
we crave control of our lives we yearn
to get better at things and we hunger
for work that has meaning these are the
things that motivate us and they they
perfectly explain open source software
this is why we do it so if we can agree
that these are the motivations we share
with everybody that all motivations are
as honorable as our own then conflicts
between us must be due to differences
about strategy about how to reach our
common lofty goals if we desire the same
hands but have simply chosen different
means
the real insufficiency maybe one of
understanding and maybe instead of
persuading them to do things our way
we'd be better served if we got better
at collaboration we need to improve our
ability not only to influence but to be
influenced and that leads me to teamwork
teams
studies show groups innovate faster they
innovate more quickly people are happier
they achieve better results they report
higher job satisfaction but of course
teams involve people and people really
cause so much of our unhappiness so in
but it I'm convinced that persuading all
those people to do things our way is not
the solution to this problem so instead
of asking how can we be more persuasive
we should perhaps be asking how can we
make better teams and Google asked this
question back in 2012 Google has a lot
of teams and they have a lot of data and
they're good at it and they really
wanted to know they wanted to be able to
predict and make good teams and so they
embarked upon a thing they called
Project Aristotle they looked at
everything they've got all their team's
they ranked their efficiency and they
measured everything and they could not
figure it out they could find no pattern
that would allow them to predict the
outcome the efficiency of a team based
on the individual qualities of the
team's members they looked at
personality they knew things that did
not matter like personality types no
matter whether the people are all the
same don't matter whether they socialize
after work doesn't matter they looked at
everything nine ways from Sunday and
they could find no pattern in the data
and so while they were serving this
problem they started looking at they
came across the idea that a group could
have an identity that was different than
the identity of the individuals in the
group and so and that led them down a
path to some research where people were
people were looking other research we're
looking at this idea they had someone
had come up with a notion that perhaps
groups have an intelligence and IQ
factor like individuals have and then
the IQ of the group is is separate
different than the IQ of any individual
in the group but something happens in
groups so that they form an identity and
when goodwill started looking
along this dimension they eventually
figured it out they eventually isolated
the quality that they could use to
predict which team was going to be high
performing the fundamental thing that
distinguishes good teams from
dysfunctional ones is how teammates
treat one another that's all there is to
it there's two basic behaviors that fold
into this one is the members of a team
speak roughly in the same proportion of
course they were psychologists so they
called this a quality and distribution
of conversational turn-taking
and this doesn't mean that in every
meeting everybody speaks the same amount
it just means like over a course of the
day I have a quote as long as everyone
got a chance to talk the team did well
but if only one person or a small group
spoke all the time
collective intelligence declined so
that's one predictor of whether teams
are gonna do well the next one is the
thing they call average social
sensitivity which and all this means
this is another fancy psychological way
of saying that members of the team could
infer how other teammates felt with
nonverbal cues they could look at the
expression on your face or they could
see your body language and they would
know what you were feeling and so these
two qualities conversational turn-taking
in average social sensitivity are really
part of these are two traits that are
part of a lot larger bundle and
psychologists call it psychological
safety this is a group culture where
members have a shared belief that their
team is safe for interpersonal
risk-taking give you a sense of
confidence that the team won't embarrass
or punish you for speaking up
it describes a climate where trust and
respect let people be comfortable being
themselves now it this is not the only
norm that's important right
psychological safety is not the only
thing teams need like a culture of
accountability and clear goals they need
other stuff like that but this is the
quality Google's needed indicates that
psychological safety is the most
critical element in making a successful
team this is what makes teams work
and making your team safe starts with
you you can set the tone of the next
conversation that you have words matter
words about the past are often about
blame and you should probably avoid them
we're about the future about solutions
they're about corrective action they're
about what goes next when you're faced
with conflict it's okay to have strong
opinions but they should be weakly held
you should have an identity but keep it
small don't bind yourself in the
straitjacket of consistency with your
past if you think back on Carnegie's
suggestions they're all open hearted and
forward-looking right they're the kinds
of things that would make psychological
safety if only we could do them and you
have to wonder why we don't what is it
that prevents us from sincerely trying
to make them like us from winning them
over from being leader why do we fail to
trust their intentions believe in their
motivations and make a safe place
consider this if you were in the middle
of a heated argument and one of your
teammates accused you of being purple
you would probably say well tell me more
about that you wouldn't have a strong
reaction to that because you are not
secretly afraid that your purple
you are not your code you are not your
past you are not your parents and you
are not responsible for everything
and I think if you pop the why can't we
come to an agreement stack all the way
to the bottom when you look deep in the
well what you come to is fear I know
this because I'm afraid and I think that
you are too but I also know something
else right fear is just the background
noise of the human condition we all have
it it doesn't really matter we can't
escape it but it needn't define us it
doesn't matter because despite it
alongside it and within it you are also
good enough I feel the need to repeat
that I stand here and I see you and I
know that you are good enough hear me
put that burden down your past does not
need to dictate your future I know that
I will concede that some situations are
someone saying that they cannot be fixed
and I'm not urging you to stay in them
right the height of sanity there is to
leave you get to go if it can't be fixed
but in situations where the problem is
miscommunication rather than pathology
the most efficient way to change
everyone's future is by taking a deep
breath and changing yourself if you want
to achieve your purpose learn these
tools of persuasion and use the power of
persuasion to make your team more
psychologically safe we are hardwired to
work together a good team is always
better than any single individual and to
build the best team you must reach
inside and find a way to be your best
self thank you
[Applause]